and then what happened was I just you
just let it go yeah years ago that's not
my life now I had to figure it out
and then once I accepted my situation I
started you're doing Chelsea Lately and
then um they got then that one year I
got animal practice the dictator a bunch
of [ __ ] you know I mean and then it's
been fine since then but my point though
is is that you know they're I believe
that that was good for me
yeah anyone listening now everyone
listening now let me just say something
right now right feedback in you know the
bad times are good you learned so much
from the well you laughing you [ __ ] nut
you all [ __ ] whip your my I can't do
what my pick out anymore I know everyone
seen it I have only seen it in a
performance that's what I'm saying like
she was saying even in performance well
just to be just to err on the safe side
since everything's really you know
dangerous right now I'm just saying
you're you're seen already by a lot as
like someone who's sexually deviant
because that's the image you you put out
so let's just err on the safe side and
don't farm on stage don't you appeal it
Toki the dumb dumb want to come out I
can't print okay though yeah Toki's
going on sabbatical on a cruise
okie-dokie your cruise but but let me
say something though in a pile give you
an example
alright a stripper great sure a stripper
goes up you write your case and shows
you Katie in a vagina that's one thing
she's performing right be born there to
see that but if people already know that
I'm old I'm kind of a stripper and I
don't touch them in a sexual way right
in a sack falls out I mean what if toki
is like my limbs now where was it what
was it in before what do you mean why
did where do those snack fall out of the
cruise ship no gotta gotta got it I have
a hole it's exactly way to put buffet
right Toki comes out the sack is up
inside of something what do you mean
exactly yeah yeah no this is the SEC I
had work clothing were hokey can breathe
got it right there like windows uh-huh
okay my jeans have windows great and
everyone said well Toki we'll stick on a
limb and go through like through like
the the potty hole yeah yeah yeah you're
pulling him out of there yes and he
brings a friend along yeah it's a part
of him being a Frank I get you're saying
yeah yeah yeah so if Toki all right so
Toki peeks his little eye out of little
window yeah yeah and a human seer sure
in a show environment okay could that
get me in trouble I don't know I don't
know he's that Toki I don't think it
should but I know he's not going I want
it I want to go inside you that's not
what Toki's doing
that's not Yankees character you would
never get at you listen first job
[Applause]
we get Cheryl to be Michael McDonald
won't talk to you Wow bro yeah
and then one day could I tell you the
most hurtful thing he did yeah
the second year I was there and I was
friends with Ike and Josh mm-hmm and I
was one weekend and I called I can I go
what are you doing
let's go watch a movie or something
because we're all out in Sonoma you know
who and Mike had invited everyone there
mm-hmm and I wasn't invited
that's rough and so for years you know I
would be scared of him and stuff but
because because eight years and then
like year four five yeah really good
friends like yeah exactly where he's
been he's all right Lee to me now yes
exactly you know I like you know what I
like guys where I have to earn their
friendship
I agree sometimes in some situations I
agree because it's like you know if you
know you look at guys like um like back
in the day when I was a young guy like
dice mm-hmm you know you guys they think
what you want but as a stand up diced
wasn't inviting in the beginning and
then once you years go by and he could
tell that you're not gonna go away you
know your own kid that's he like in it
then when there's like eight Jing you
used to call me ching-ching are you
doing and you go oh my god you know if
you hadn't done that right away and he
still doesn't know my name but if I saw
you on [ __ ] YouTube or whatever but
like I'm glad that he I had to earn his
you know min respect yeah prefer I
prefer when people are just nice that's
good I mean yeah
yeah you know yeah a little bit better
but don't sometimes people don't turn no
this is true some people just stay dicks
yes that's true and I have I've had to
learn that too
mm-hmm you're not gonna like everybody
and not everybody's gonna like you and
but in this rule advice [ __ ] [ __ ]
that is true yeah I think there are
because you've always been a nice guy
but you also have the talent hear me out
okay
you're nice okay so you're cute as [ __ ]
that's cool what thanks cool you're
welcome yeah you're welcome
thank you okay am i all right you're
great thank you
you're adorable I want to that's all I
wanted I your hair loopies phenomen okay
okay let's move on
[Music]